on this Saturday night the facts are in
now the debate begins after six weeks of
testimony lawyers make the case about
invoking the emergencies act freedom of
No One Is Safe unless the freedom of
everyone is safe plus we check the
temperature on where Canadians stand on
the issue
a mother's dire plea how much money do
they ask for I think it was five hundred
dollars immediately teen boys exploited
online what inflation the Black Friday
Bonanza boosting online sales across the
border and coaches call the candid
comments and the yellow card ahead of
Canada's next World Cup Showdown
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
the facts are in but the emergencies act
inquiry is not over yet after six weeks
of grueling testimony more than 75
Witnesses and several thousand documents
entered into evidence lawyers are now
arguing over what it all means and if
the government went too far or was
warranted and invoking the emergencies
act last winter David Aiken has our top
story tonight
prime minister Justin Trudeau was the
last of nearly 70 witnesses to testify
at the public order emergency commission
but the commission's work is far from
done now lawyers and experts are
pleading their case to commissioner
Justice Paul Rouleau these are summaries
of the position of the various parties
the government's lawyer said the
evidence strongly supports the decision
to invoke the emergencies act the
measures taken for dealing with the
emergency were proportional
effective time limited and Charter
compliant not so fast say a host of
opponents to that view first that they
interfered with provincial powers
and second that they infringed on the
rights of citizens seven provinces
advised the government of Canada that
they did not support the invocation of
the act in their province that there was
no need and that they had the capability
and authorities to deal with the
situation civil liberties groups raised
the alarm that the Trudeau government's
actions could make it easier for future
governments to violate the rights of
Canadians in the name of an emergency
freedom of No One Is Safe unless the
freedom of everyone is safe
we urge the commission to bear this
tenant in mind as it examines what the
government did and considers what future
governments may do and a lawyer
representing a group of the Ottawa
Convoy protesters argued Trudeau should
lose his job if there ever was a time
for a prime minister to step down now is
that time and yet a poll done in
mid-october found that most Canadians
about two-thirds think otherwise in fact
they think that Trudeau's decision to
invoke the emergencies Act was the right
call and a majority in every region of
the country held that view even if it
was a narrow majority in Alberta
Saskatchewan and Manitoba the next phase
of the commission's work begins Monday
with more than 50 experts and academics
ready to give their advice on everything
from criminal law and policing powers to
freedom of expression and even
cryptocurrency David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
Canada's foreign affairs minister is
starting to speak out more about China
and its potential interference here in
this country but Melanie Jolie is
stopping short of confirming potential
interference in the 2019 federal
election as we first reported here on
global news Mercedes Stevenson joins us
now with more on this week's the West
block Mercedes
far a foreign affairs minister Melanie
zholi has been ramping up her criticism
of China saying earlier this month that
Canadians should consider the quote
geopolitical risks of doing business in
China and at the G20 just 10 days ago
Jolie spoke with her Chinese counterpart
saying that Canada won't accept any form
of meddling in our governments in our
elections and we won't tolerate any form
of foreign interference in Canada in an
interview to air on this week's the West
block Jolie said the government needs to
do more to deal with foreign
interference and China's increasingly
aggressive foreign policy there is a
growing concern on the part of you know
obviously us but also and the Americans
and also our European allies that China
is bit by bit not respecting
International Norms or trying to bend or
change these International Norms to its
own benefits also China is investing
massively in their own in its own
military capacities and therefore this
is changing the security environment so
that's why we need to step up our game
when asked Minister Jolie would not say
however if she was briefed by thesis
about alleged attempts of foreign
interference by China in the 2019
election a story first reported by
global news's Sam Cooper
Jolie would only say that she wasn't the
foreign affairs minister during the time
period when the alleged attempts at
interference took place
well I was not a foreign minister uh
when you know uh the allegations uh of
the report of the story uh were made
what I can tell you though that in
general foreign interference is
intolerable
in general we will not accept any
foreign States meddling in our you know
country's Affairs Melanie Jolie was the
Minister of Foreign Affairs at the time
when sources say the briefings took
place January of 2022 so we still don't
know if she received one Jolie did
however raise additional concerns about
foreign interference in Canada both
online and through propaganda as major
concerns she has but I'm also concerned
is the question of foreign interference
online and Mercedes this is affecting
all our democracies it's something that
our friends the Americans have to deal
with our European Partners as well and
so this is something that I take very
seriously on the margin of the UN
General Assembly we'll have more on how
the government plans to deal with China
from the foreign affairs minister as
well as an analysis of the prime
minister's testimony at the emergencies
act commission ahead on on the show
tomorrow pharah okay Mercedes Stevenson
thank you so much for that and again you
can catch the full interview tomorrow
morning on the west block right here on
global
late night protests erupted in Northwest
China a day after a deadly fire engulfed
an apartment block trapping residents
and killing at least 10 people
[Applause]
this dramatic video shows protesters
pushing barriers shouting for the
government to end the lockdown imposed
in early August which officials did
today following public pressure people
living in the building say strict
coveted restrictions made it difficult
to escape the Flames several major
cities including Beijing are
experiencing a surge in cases and are
ramping up construction of quarantine
facilities and field hospitals again
a landslide on the Italian island of
iskia off the coast of Naples swept away
lampposts and overturned cars early this
morning
[Applause]
it comes after torrential rain triggered
flooding overnight the death toll is
still unclear but an Italian government
official says around 10 people are
missing the last fatal Landslide on the
island was in 2006 when a father and his
three daughters were killed
there may be a glimmer of hope to end a
simmering African conflict that's forced
tens of thousands of people to flee
their homes in recent months the rebel
group M23 has seized several towns in
the eastern part of the Democratic
Republic of the Congo there is now a new
ceasefire in place as of this Friday but
as Mike Armstrong explains the question
is whether it'll hold
please
with each offensive by M23 more
Congolese are pushed from their homes
and the drc's province of North kivu
according to the UN just in the last
month close to 200 000 people have
become refugees in their own country
says he fled his village not out of fear
but out of panic
the drc's armed forces have had their
hands full with M23 the tutsi-led rebel
militia was formed 10 years ago in 2012
it briefly captured and occupied the
provincial capital of Goma it was
eventually pushed out of the country
until the Resurgence this year
Congolese government accuses neighboring
Rwanda of supporting the group something
Rwanda denies but the United Nations
said in August there is solid evidence
Rwandan soldiers have fought alongside
m-23 troops
now there is new help for the Congolese
Army Kenya and Burundi have sent
soldiers as part of a regional Force to
fight m-23 and other militias Uganda is
set to send soldiers as well the United
Nations has had troops on the ground for
more than 20 years and spent billions
but there are still more than 100 active
militia groups in addition to m-23 the
new Regional Force isn't supposed to be
about peacekeeping
Congolese Army's spokesperson says the
regional force is on a purely offensive
Mission now there is a ceasefire
agreement signed this week there was a
Summit held in Angola aimed at calming
growing tensions between Congo and
Rwanda it ended with a declaration that
fighting was to stop as of Friday but
M23 was not part of the talks in a
statement the group says it accepts the
ceasefire but will defend itself if
attacked the current police government
meanwhile is promising that if peace
isn't achieved with the agreement it is
prepared to take action
the foreign affairs minister says any
group that doesn't take the hand of
Peace will be fought by the new Regional
Force while protesters took to the
streets of Goma after the agreement was
signed they marched on the French and
British consulates they say to denounce
the international community's silence at
what's going on Mike Armstrong Global
News
in Ukraine civilians are fleeing the
southern city of Hassan after days of
intensive shelling by Russian forces
crews are scrambling to restore heat
electricity and water services Hassan
was among several cities to face heavy
Russian Artillery fire and drone attacks
in recent days Moscow has ratcheted up
its attacks on critical infrastructure
after several Battlefield setbacks
millions of ukrainians have been
suffering power cuts across the country
supply chain concerns ahead of Christmas
coming up forecasts show Big Holiday
spending in the U.S but how people are
paying has some analysts worried
[Music]
Irene Cara who produced some of the most
iconic pop anthems at the 80s has passed
away at the age of 63. her publicist
announced the news this morning on
social media writing a cause of death
was currently unknown the Oscar Golden
Globe and Grammy winning singer and
actress was best known for the theme
songs of Fame and Flashdance
in some parts of Canada Black Friday
wasn't as busy as expected but in the
U.S despite near record high inflation
American Shoppers spent a record 9.1
billion dollars online it's a positive
sign for retailers seeing slow sales
throughout 2022. as Jennifer Johnson
reports Americans are not only buying
big but they're traveling far and wide
this Thanksgiving weekend
from Black Friday to small business
Saturday to Cyber Monday U.S retailers
are desperate for business and already
consumers are opening up their wallets
this holiday season online spending on
Black Friday was up 2.3 percent and
beyond that we're expecting retail sales
during the holiday season to grow
between six and eight percent to 960
billion dollars the growth comes as
consumer prices keep rising up 7.7
percent from this time last year
Shoppers are spending but one poll shows
48 percent are using their credit cards
which concern some analysts a lot of
people have cut their savings rate
they've dipped into their savings
account and they are running up their
credit card using credit more than debit
166 million people are expected to shop
over the long Thanksgiving weekend break
that's up more than 8 million from last
year retailers want Shoppers in their
stores and malls something they haven't
seen much of lately a lot of people were
skeptical during the pandemic and to see
a crowd like we have today it's nice to
see with the holiday shopping season
here analysts are keeping a close eye on
possible labor problems some protests
and walkouts against Amazon have begun
and there are concerns about a potential
rail strike in December that could
further slow down the already slow
supply chain but this weekend anyway
trains planes and Automobiles are on the
move as at least 55 million Americans
travel to loved ones most are driving
despite high gas prices but millions of
others are braving the skies where air
ticket prices are up about five percent
from 2019. it's a 13-hour trip and the
ticket costs 1058 pre-holiday travel has
been relatively smooth but some bad
weather is moving in including wintry
mixes in New England and the Great Lakes
region and heavy precipitation is
hitting parts of Texas with snow also
falling in normally warm El Paso but the
worst of the weather is expected on
Sunday which according to the U.S
Transportation Security Administration
is the busiest travel day of the year
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
battling sex torsion ahead the youth
were becoming at
RCMP in Manitoba say a 25 year old woman
and her two-year-old child are safe
after they were allegedly abducted on
the side of a highway near Portage la
Prairie yesterday afternoon
the victim and the male suspect were not
known to each other it was later
determined that she came across the male
suspect who was pretending to be in
medical distress by the side of the road
she stopped her vehicle to assist at
which time he got into the vehicle and
demanded that she drive him to Winnipeg
this was an extremely difficult
situation and we'd like to acknowledge
the victim who did everything she could
to keep herself and her child safe
police are now in the hunt for 62 year
old Michael Stephen klimchuk of Winnipeg
he's wanted on numerous charges
including kidnapping and forcible
confinement
a stark warning from police agencies
about a significant rise in online
sexual exploitation of children it's
known as sextortion Internet
blackmailers Target youth but the
largest increase in cases involves teen
boys for this week's episode of the new
reality Dallas Flex hog reports on this
disturbing trend
this mom who we are calling Sarah to
protect her identity is speaking out to
warn other parents after her teenage son
was a victim of extortion how much money
did they ask for I think it was 500
immediately or the video would be shared
with all of his friends and family
sextortion is a form of online blackmail
where criminals deceive children and
teens through various digital platforms
to obtain explicit images victims are
then extorted for money or more material
this type of crime has been growing at
an alarming rate especially in 2022. at
the start of the year we were noting in
the first six months that we had had 150
percent increase in the number of
reports related to sex extortion 90 of
the the extortion victims that are
reporting to us are young males the
perpetrator convinced Sarah's son who
was 15 years old at the time to send a
sexually explicit video he believed he
was flirting with a young woman this
person led him to believe they were
sexting let's do it on video while the
video was recorded and then used it as
blackmail for the money girls are being
targeted to experts say but the
offenders tend to be interested in them
sexually so girls are being blackmailed
for more content the perpetrators
extorting boys are often tied to
organized crime boys are getting
extorted for money the boys will send a
picture or a video they will then get a
message immediately by saying well
thanks for the picture but I want money
now in recent years a terrifying pattern
has emerged some extortion victims
fearing No Way Out have taken their own
lives sometimes within hours of being
targeted it is truly terrifying to have
this happen to you there is no safe
place there's nowhere to retreat from
these images and the harassment that
follows them as for Sarah her son
blocked the extorter immediately but it
didn't help the offender sent the video
to to her son's friends and family on
Facebook he lost his girlfriend he also
lost a lot of his friends it's
heartbreaking to watch their life
crumble to help with the emotional toll
Sarah made sure her son was receiving
counseling and is relieved he came to
her so she could help
had we not done that immediately and
taken such fast action I don't think
we'd have our son today Dallas flexhog
Global News
to learn more about Dallas historic and
to the rise in teens extortion watch the
new reality tonight on global
getting ready for Canada versus Croatia
what's at stake for tomorrow's Do or Die
World Cup game
[Music]
to the FIFA World Cup now as the
Canadian men's team gears up for their
high stakes Showdown against Croatia
tomorrow now it stirred some controversy
already in an interview earlier this
week coach John Herdman said they were
going to quote F Croatia he later
clarified he was impassioned and he
meant no disrespect today he had much
more to say about their matchup
there's definitely a lot at stake for
Canada not only are they aiming to make
their first goal in a World Cup ever
they need to pick enough points against
Croatia and Morocco next week to advance
to the next stage and joining me now
from Qatar is Joshua cloak a writer for
the athletic who's been closely
following the World's Cup journey of the
Canadian men's team actually he has a
book about it called the voyagers uh
Josh great to see you let me start with
those comments you heard them how does
that reflect the mindset in terms of
what's going on going into this match
well I mean this Canadian men's national
team has always been under John Herdman
fearless and I think if you're John
Herdman you probably look at this team
uh after the loss against Belgium and
and you might see some some heads
hanging low and you need to kind of
galvanize your team so by him kind of
standing up for his team in front of the
media I think that's an effort to kind
of remind this this team that their
World Cup is far from over even after a
loss in the first game
Josh what's Canada doing to prepare
right now I mean what have they learned
from their previous game with Belgium
John Herdman said today in his media
availability that Belgium and Croatia
are remarkably different teams and
they're going to be different tests so I
think what you're going to see is that
um Canada needs to play a little more
tactically structured game maybe not
just go after the game as fast as they
did I expect Canada to put a little few
more players in the Midfield and try to
slow down uh the Temple of possession
try and wait Croatia out they played a
real run and Gun style against Belgium
and I don't know if that's going to work
against Croatia a team that's very very
smart off the ball uh so that's probably
what they learned going forward is that
they're going to have to be a little
more tactically inventive okay smart off
the ball is one thing you said what
other strengths and weaknesses should we
know about Croatia and should Canada
take note of
I mean they are a remarkably experienced
side led by Luca Modric who is arguably
the best midfielder of this generation
they have the ability to just kind of
wait to use out uh and be very very
patient off the ball again they're a
remarkably smart team and I think what
you're going to find is you know whereas
Belgium looked to be kind of uh phased
by Canada's pace and verticality Croatia
might not be and obviously with all the
con you know the controversy surrounding
this game uh you think that Croatia is
probably going to be able to get up for
this a little bit more because they feel
that they've been disrespected by John
Herdman so there's probably some
emotions that play for them as well
all right Joshua cloak from cutter thank
you so much
thank you
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser
tonight's your Canada is Port Stanley
Ontario take a look at this this is on
the North shore of Lake Erie Cody Evans
snapped this perfect pick what he's
calling Poseidon's wrath during that
Wicked Lake Effect snowstorm that buried
Buffalo until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other good night
thank you